So this is indeed a general idea of the
expectation maximization, or EM algorithm.
So in all the EM algorithms, we
introduce a hidden variable to help us
solve the problem more easily.
In our case, the hidden variable is a
binary variable for each occurrence of
word.
And this binary variable would indicate
whether the world has been generated
from theta on Sunday or theater Super
B.
And here we show some possible values
of these variables.
For example for the it's from
Background, Z value is 1 and text on
the other hand is from the topic.
Then it's 0 for Z etc.
Now, of course we don't observe those Z
values.
We just imagine there are such a social
values of Z attached to all the words.
And that's why we call these hidden
variables.
Now the idea that we talked about
before for predicting the word
distribution that has been used with
the general the world is it'll predict
this.
The value of this hidden variable.
And
So.
The algorithm, the EM algorithm then
would work as follows.
First will initialize all the
parameters with random values.
In our case the parameters are mainly
the probability of a word given by
status update.
So this is the initialization stage.
It is initialized values would allow us
to use Bayes rule to take a guess of
these Z values.
So will guess these values we can say
for sure whether taxes from background
or not, but we can have our guesses.
This is given by this formula.
It's called E-step.
And so the algorithm would then try to
use the E Step 2 gas.
These Z values.
After that it would then invoke another
spec step called M-step.
In this step we simply take advantage
of the inferred values and then just
group words that are in the same
distribution like this from background,
including this as well.
We can then normalize the count to estimate
the probabilities or to revise our
estimate of the parameters.
So let me also illustrate we can group
the words that are believed to have
come from Cedar sub D and as text
mining algorithm for example and
clustering.
And we had group them together.
To help us re estimate the parameters.
That were interested in so these will
help us re estimate these parameters.
But note that before we just set these
parameter values randomly, But with
this guess we will have a somewhat
improved estimate of this.
Of course, we don't know exactly
whether it's zero or one, so we're not
going to really do the split in
hardware, but rather we can do those
soft split and this is what happened
here.
So we're going to adjust the count.
By the probability that we believe this
would has been generated by using the
theta sub d.
And you can see this.
Where does this come from?
Well, this has come from here right
from the E step.
So the EM algorithm with iteratively
improve our initial estimate of
parameters by using E-step first and
then M step.
the E step is to augment the data with
additional information like Z.
And the M step is to take advantage of
the additional information to separate
the data to split the data accounts and
then collect the right data counts.
re estimate our parameters.
And then once we have a new generation
of parameters, we're going to repeat
this.
We're going to use the E-step again to
improve our estimate of the hidden
variables, and then that would lead to
another generation of re estimate the
parameters.
For the word distribution that we're
interested in.
OK, so as I said, the bridge between
the two is really variable Z hidden
variable, which indicates how likely
this world is from the topic word
distributions theta sub d.
So this slide has a lot of content and
you may need to pause the video to
digest it, but this basically captured
the essence of EM algorithm.
Start with initial values that are
often randomly set.
And then we invoke E step followed by M
step to get an improved setting of
parameters, and then we repeat this.
So this is a hill climbing algorithm
that would gradually improve the
estimate of parameters and as I will
explain later, there's some guarantee
for reaching a local maximum
of the likelihood function.
So let's take a look at the computation
for specific case.
So these formulas are the EM formulas
that you see before, and you can also
see there are superscripts here N to
indicate the generation of parameters.
I go here.
For example, we have N + 1.
That means we have improved parameters
from here to.
here we have improvement.
So in this setting we have assumed that
the two models have equal probabilities
and the background model is known.
So what are the relevant statistics?
Well, these are the word counts.
So assume we have just 4 words and
their counts are like this and this is
our background model that assigns high
probabilities to common words like the.
An in the first iteration you can
picture what would happen.
Well, we first we initialize all
the values.
So here this probability that we're
interested in is normalized into an
uniform distribution over all the
words.
And then the E step would give us a
guess.
Of the distribution that has been used
to generate each word, we can see we
have different probabilities for
different words.
Why that's be cause these words have
different probabilities in the
background.
So even though the two distributions
are equally likely, and then our
initialization says uniform
distribution because of the difference
in the background world distribution,
we have different guest probabilities.
So these words are believed to be more
likely from the topic.
These, on the other hand, are less
likely probably from background.
So once we have the Z values, we know
in the E step these probabilities
would be used to adjust the counts.
So 4 must be multiplied by this point
three three in order to get the allocated
counts toward the topic.
And this is done by this
multiplication.
Note that if our guess says this is 100%.
If this is 1.0
Then we just get the full Council of
this word for this topic.
But in general, as I said, it's not
going to be 1.0, so we're going to just
get some percentage of the counts
toward this topic, and then we simply
normalize these counts.
To have a new generation of practice
mate so you can see, compare this with
the old one which is here.
So compare this with this one and will
see at the probability is different.
Not only that, we also see some words
that are believed to have come from the
topic.
We have high probability like this one
text.
And of course, this new generation of
parameters would allow us to further
adjust the infer the latent variable or
hidden variable values.
So we have a new generation of values
because of the E step based on the new
generation of parameters.
And this these new in further values of
these will give us then another
generation of the estimate of
probabilities of the words.
And so on so forth.
So this is what would actually happen
when we compute these probabilities
using the EM algorithm.
And as you can see in the last rule where
we showed the log like code and the
likelihood is increasing as we do the
iteration.
And note that these log likelihood is
negative becausw the probability is
between zero and one when you take
logarithm, it becomes a negative value.
What's also interesting is do not last
column, and these are the inferred word
split, and these are the probabilities
that a word is believed to have come
from one distribution.
In this case the topic distribution,
and you might wonder whether this would
be also useful because our main goal is
to estimate these word distribution
right?
So this is our primary goal.
We hope to have a more discriminating
world distribution.
But the last column is also by product
and this actually can also be very
useful and you can think about that.
And one use is to.
For example, is made to what extent
this document has covered background
words.
And this when we add this up or take
the average will kind of know to what
extent it has covered background versus
content words that are not explained
well by the background.